ELECTION FRAUD.
THE PARTY, MORE THAN 40% OF THE
VOTE.
NEW DETAILS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
CASUALTIES IN UKRAINE.
THE BIDEN MINISTRATION SAYS
MORE THAN 100,000 RUSSIAN
TROOPS ARE BEING KILLED OR
WOUNDED IN UKRAINE SINCE
DECEMBER.
THE AMERICAN GOVERNMENT SAYS
THAT IS PROOF THAT RUSSIA'S WAR
HAS BACKFIRED.
CNN CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY CORRESPONDENT, NICK
PATON WALSH, IS LIVE IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA FOR US.
AND YOU WOULD EXPECT TO HAVE
GOT SOME SORT OF RESPONSE ON
THOSE NUMBERS, CERTAINLY SOUNDS
SIGNIFICANT ON RUSSIAN DEATHS
FROM THE KREMLIN, WHAT HAVE WE
HEARD?
>> THE KREMLIN SPOKESPERSON,
DIMITRI, HAS TOLD REPORTERS
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
ABSOLUTELY NO WAY OF BEING ABLE
TO ESTIMATE RUSSIAN CASUALTIES
AND WE SHOULD LOOK TO THE LAST
OFFICIAL STATEMENT FROM THE
RUSSIAN MINISTRY OF DEFENSE,
JUST PLUS 6000 DEATHS IS THEIR
LATEST STATEMENT.
LOOK, JOHN KIRBY, THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL SPOKES PERSON,
WHEN HE GAVE THIS FIGURE, IT'S,
YOU KNOW, SUSPICIOUSLY AROUND,
TO BE HONEST.
THAT IS BASED ON INTELLIGENCE
THAT HAD BEEN DOWNGRADED.
ESSENTIALLY CLASSIFY,
DECLASSIFY AS THE FRONT WORK
BEING RELEASED PUBLICLY.
WENT ON TO GET MORE DETAILS,
MAKES SLIGHTLY MORE SENSE OF
IT.
20,000 DIED, THE REMAINING
80,000 ARE INJURED, THAT MAYBE,
WE DON'T KNOW, THAT MAY BE THE
RESULT OF THEIR ASSESSMENT, FOR
EVERY PERSON WHO, DIES FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE INJURED IN A
NORMAL BATTLEFIELD.
THAT'S CERTAINLY THE RATIO THAT
NATO HOPES TO OBTAIN AND ITS
OPERATIONS.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE SAID HALF
OF THOSE 20,000 DEAD WERE
WAGNER FIGHTERS.
THAT WOULD PROBABLY LOCATE THEM
IN THE EXCEPTIONALLY GRISLY
BATTLE FOR BAKHMUT WE SAW TAKE
PLACE SINCE OCTOBER OR
NOVEMBER.
THE KEY FOCUS OF RUSSIA'S
MILITARY ACTIVITIES SINCE THEN,
THE GRISLY FOCUS OF THEIR
WINTER COUNTEROFFENSIVE,
UTTERLY FUTILE, FRANKLY.
AND IN THE LAST FEW DAYS, WE'VE
SEEN KEY RUSSIAN MILITARY
FIGURE, YOU'VE BEEN A PRIGOZHIN
AHEAD OF THAT WAGNER GROUP COME
FORWARD AND SAY, WITHOUT MORE
ARTILLERY SHELLS, HE'S NOT SURE
THESE GUYS CAN HANG ON IN
BAKHMUT.
HE'S MADE MISLEADING STATEMENTS
BEFORE, WE SIMPLY DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT'S COMING FROM.
AT THE SAME TIME, UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS HAVE SAID THEY'RE
PUSHING BACK.
MANAGING TO GET RUSSIANS TO
LEAVE POSITIONS.
THIS IS BEEN A BACK AND FORTH
FOR MONTHS NOW.
IT'S ONE WHERE THE LAST FEW
WEEKS, WE'VE BEGUN TO GET THE
FEELING RUSSIA THOUGHT I HAD
THE HIGH GROUND, HAD THE
CAPACITY, POTENTIALLY, TO
ENCIRCLE THE REMAINING
UKRAINIAN TROOPS INSIDE.
INSIDE THAT CITY.
IT SEEMS TO BE REVERSING.
A BACK AND FORTH THAT MAY
CONTINUE TO MOVE.
ON BUT I THINK THE MESSAGE WE
CAN TAKE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
CERTAINLY WITH THESE NUMBERS,
WHICH LACK OF EVIDENCE,
CERTAINLY BEHIND THEM.
THEY DO CERTAINLY SPEAK OF AN
APPALLING WINTER THAT RUSSIA
HAS HAD.
THE FACT THAT THE BIDEN
MINISTRATION IS VERY KEEN TO BE
BEHIND THIS FORTHCOMING
UKRAINIAN COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
REMINDING THE WORLD HOW
CATASTROPHICALLY BAD RUSSIAN
DECISIONS ARE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, HOW THEIR DECISION
TO FIGHT FOR THE SYMBOLIC BUT
STRATEGICALLY NOT VERY USEFUL
CITY OF BAKHMUT, IT HAS TAKEN
UP WHAT REMAINING RESOURCES
THEY HAVE.
BECKY, WE SPOKE TO RUSSIAN
CONVICTS WHO WERE RECRUITED --
SENT TO THE FRONT LINE TO FIGHT
INJURED, AND THEN CALLED US
FROM THE HOSPITAL TO SAY
THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
SENT BACK TO THE FRONT LINE
STILL INJURED.
THERE REALLY APPEARS THAT
STRAINING THE RESOURCES ON THE
HUMAN LEVEL THAT THEY'RE
SENDING TO THAT FRONTLINE.
THAT CERTAINLY SPEAKS OF
DESPERATION AHEAD OF THIS
UKRAINIAN COUNTEROFFENSIVE,
INTO WHICH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF NATO WEAPONRY, TRAINING, AND
PLANNING APPEAR TO HAVE GONE, A
SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
TRAINING THE ACRANIA FOR A
SURPRISE ATTACK.
WE ARE SEEING INDICATIONS HERE
IN ZAPORIZHZHIA THAT SOME OF
THAT COUNTEROFFENSIVE MAYBE
BEGINNING ARE BEGINNING TO HAVE
ITS PEARLY YOU'D, IMPOSSIBLE TO
TELL, UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
OBVIOUSLY WON'T TELL US WHEN
THEY'RE STARTING.
VERY STARK INDICTMENT WHERE
RUSSIA IS AHEAD OF T